there's all these people who is
constantly reinvented themselves so
here's a PhD student in Stanford a
really influential work of approximation
arguments if you have a linear program
realization that you need rounded so
that those who go to correct it ended a
postdoc you AT&T in at UPenn he can have
did important work in data streams
recently he's been doing very important
to work on approximation algorithms for
multi-armed bandit problems so further
ado succinct representations and
efficient albums based on linear program
thank you Andrew and thank you everyone
for waking up and on this they call it
on a four day long conference I would be
talking about sucks in representations
because I'm told that that was the
innovation of this entire workshop that
it was sucks in the talks are not
necessarily that suck sent so this is
joint work with coke Shannon who is now
in Google and the paper is available in
archive at this number okay so what I
want to start with talking about is
optimization is intimately connected
with the representation you start from
and this is something we know this is
something we've always seen in
undergraduate textbooks the particular
problem i would talk about in this talk
is a linear program which is a simple
maximization problem it's a packing
problem if you see that feels like i am
packing a times X to be less than equal
to B and I would assume all the numbers
involved a all the vectors CB are all
positive there is a term for this this
is known as positive linear programming
okay now we also know in from
combinatorial optimization that an LP
has many many many equivalent
formulations any of you who has seen
max-flow min-cut you can probably right
many different LPS which try to capture
the same thing now the question is which
one of these would you choose to solve a
particular problem and that can have
profound impact on what you what
solution you actually get if you think
about it and in the context of this
workshop big
is about finding approximately optimum
solutions because finding the exact
optimum might just be very hard or you
may not even be interested in it it may
not be relevant now we've always seen
that things are equivalent to each other
and therefore two formulations are
equivalent the proof of equivalency
would always see is equivalence at
optimality that does not say anything
about a particular approximation
solution and this is the key point which
would be the start of this talk and this
is a fundamental question because if we
step back and say that we will only
solve these problems approximately that
opens up a completely new can of
questions and hopefully I will convince
you by towards the end of this talk that
sucks inch representation has something
to do with efficient approximate
optimization now we said there are many
different formula equivalent
formulations of a linear program what is
the most basic notion of equivalence
that would come to your mind anyone a
primal or a dual formulation we all know
that using strong duality for linear
programs these two things are to some
extent combinatorially describe the same
structure you have complementary
slackness you have so many different
tools but suppose I solved the primal
linear program approximately what do I
know about that dual nothing and I would
sort of impress upon you that or try to
that depending on the problem you care
about you may be better off starting
from the dual of what you wanted to
solve so this talk would be about
resource constraint computation and
particularly models in which you cannot
just enumerate through all kinds of
constraints validate all of them in
particular complementary slackness
conditions and the reason
the particular example I will choose I
will make sure that there are
exponentially many constraints in the
primal or exponentially many variables
in the duel so validating complementary
slackness condition this is simply
infeasible the particular problem is
maximum matching I would just for this
talk compare cardinality maximum
cardinality matching and i would
consider non bipartite graphs
cardinality matching in bipartite graphs
is really simple however weighted
bipartite graphs are not simple I would
not be talking about weighted graphs in
this talk there are some results in the
paper so before I proceed further what
is a model I would be talking about and
this is Big Data so I would talk about
the semi streaming model in I don't know
if this was defined in the boot camp so
I have a graph with n nodes and M edges
and m is much much larger than n
otherwise you could have just stored the
graph and you're done I see the
definition of semi streaming being
little O of M edges that you cannot
store all the edges there can be other
definitions some people prefer n poly
log in I think I don't see a difference
between n poly log and n to the 1 plus
little o of 1 as long as both are much
less than n the format of the input
would be a list of unordered edges and
you would make you sequential passes
over that list it's a standard streaming
model the point I want to say is the
streaming model in itself is not the
most exciting thing in the world but
what it lets us do is really interesting
if you have sort of heard through talks
for at least the first two days were
very heavy on streaming if you think
about the techniques that came out from
looking at problems of the lens of
streaming those techniques are far more
interesting than the model themselves
and that is the single most reason we
should study the semi streaming model
this particular result will be about
adaptivity and access to
data I'll come to that in a second the
particular result I would show you is
that in this kind of a world in a semi
streaming world i can compute a 1 minus
epsilon approximation to the maximum
cardinality non bipartite matching using
p by epsilon passes n to the 1 plus 1 by
p space and that running time where p is
some constant if you think p is like 10
the space requirement is n to the 1.1
it's almost linear and the nice thing of
choosing this notion of p is any poly
log factor can be simply absorbed in the
polynomial term it just makes your
writing much much much simpler okay so
that being said one of the reasons I
have already said that the reason for
looking at streaming is good streaming
algorithms give us good algorithms and
it should be somewhat obvious but the
ta's the algorithms I will present to
you will bead of the following form they
would use what Andrew talked about is
homomorphic sketches or homomorphic
computation they would involve taking in
a product and that's where the running
time the dominant term of running time
will come from and I will assume once
the inner products are computed some
central server can do computation in
almost linear time and space as we have
heard through this workshop sketching or
inner product would allow you good
dynamic graph algorithms and we talked
about this and we've also seen if you
can do sketching or inner product you
get good parallel algorithms so except
the point to this sounds like a lot of
interesting things can be done and I
also think this model of what can you
compute given a few sketches of a data
is a fundamental question in its own
right and it reminds me of the
compressed sensing or compressive
sensing models we saw talk of cloud
computing this is a very natural model
to ask questions that brings me to
MapReduce
everybody has their own MapReduce
definitions I may or may not have one of
them I believe any reasonable model of
computation should allow the points 1
and 2 which are up there because if you
do not have a central server which
cannot do it which is so weak then you
probably need a bigger boat and but
there is a lot of discussion on map
reduce your mileage on this may vary so
without further ado let me get to the
main result to recap I'm going to talk
about a problem where you're given a
list of edges you can compute sketches
in a product and I would ask the
question how many rounds would you need
to solve the maximum matching problem 2
1 minus 1 1 minus epsilon approximation
for any given epsilon greater than 0
okay the key and what is most exciting
to me of this stock would be the
following I will not improve the number
of rounds but what will i do I will
impress upon you that the number of
rounds which need to depend on each
other is small and therefore the only
time I would need to access data would
be much smaller than the total number of
iterations and that is an interesting
angle in itself so this is the standard
LP for matching so any questions about
the plan it's just too early in the
morning okay since it's too early in the
morning let's begin with a linear
program this is non bipartite matching
it's a standard definition you are not
this is exactly is in all textbook you
would see i define a set of odd set
where the this is the cardinality of you
that's a very natural definition and
this is my linear program where y IJ for
an edge IJ is in an integral solution
the indicator variable weather i J is in
my matching if it is it is one otherwise
it is zero and when I write a linear
program it is a fraction
relaxation of it and the constraints are
oops the constraints are each edge is
matched at most once and this is the
classic odd set constraints which rules
out that if you have a triangle you do
not select all edges of the triangle
with weights half half and half because
then you would think you have a matching
of size 3 by 2 but you cannot get a
matching of size more than one and in
fact if you ignore these odd set
constraints you cannot have an
approximation better than two-thirds ok
so this is the standard linear program
and this constraint is written for all
odd sides so this is exponential there
are exponentially many constraints here
ok now I want to do a 1 minus epsilon 1
minus 2 epsilon approximation so what
should I focus on I don't have to solve
the huge LP for that for that it turns
out that if I restrict my odd sets to a
size of at most 1 by epsilon then the
relaxation is a one- order epsilon
approximation to the original one the
reason vicar is that if you see for very
large or sets the gap between this and
this side assuming these constraints are
tight would be something say say
cardinality of you is 11 so on the right
hand side you would have 5 and on this
side you would have 5.5 and so this gap
will shrink if you look at larger and
larger sets so if you are interested in
1 minus epsilon approximation it
suffices that you just subsample or
throw away all the other constraints and
that's a linear program you want to work
with so questions about the linear
program at this point ok
so what's our plan we want to solve this
linear program and once I get a solution
to this I will round this linear program
and construct a magic rounding we've
always done rounding we can round
anything that moves I'll not talk about
rounding in this talk what I will talk
about in this talk is how to solve that
LP approximately okay now approximately
solving LPS has been an incredibly rich
rich research enterprise it's a
never-ending Road it's a very exciting
Road all of these techniques eventually
at its heart boiled down to some kind of
an exponential weighted gradient descent
method and this has been not just in
theoretical computer science community
this has been invented in many different
communities and just the incomplete list
of what I could think of in sort of
theory CS and theory has many different
connotations here these people and some
of them are also in the audience Neil
Young is here and there has been an
incredible amount of research on this i
would point everyone to the survey by
aurora hassan Caillat in theory of
computing they describe a very
comprehensive history of this problem I
am going to talk in this particular talk
about the two methods multiplicative
weight update method and a modification
of it fashional packing and covering and
sort of use those ideas okay so what is
the canonical setup I want to solve that
LP in particular for the cardinality
matching the vector C is all once the X
is actually the y IJ you looked at these
were the packing constraints that every
vertex is matched to at most one edge
and the odd sets do not have too many
edges so instead of solving that problem
I would say
módulo slipping a few details under the
rug I need to solve this decision
problem if you think about it I wanted a
maximization I just said let's just
figure out if there is a feasible
solution which is large enough for
particular assignment of better and i
will keep raising better and at some
point that should give me a near maximum
solution okay okay now all these methods
not all but most of them which have
better convergence assume that you are
given some part sort of a weaker
approximation and you saw some talks
yesterday about how to subsequently
refine polytopes and get better and
better solutions so we'll assume we are
given a ballpark pollito p which is easy
to optimize over and the important
parameter there would be this notion of
Rho which is the width all it says is
this ballpark polytope where it's easy
to solve the problem in if I pick any
point in that polytope or this number
you can think of this as a condition
number is not very large and this will
control the convergence okay with that
definition let's see the multiplicative
weight update method so imagine your
ballpark polytope is this very large
circle in the actual feasibility region
you are interested is the shaded circle
now what we would do is at any point of
time in the multiplicative weight update
you would look at a particular direction
of optimization and then you would look
at the plane which is normal to it and
the question which would be posed to a
helper or an Oracle is the following
give me a point which is on the same
side as the feasible region along this
direction so if that is my if the red
arrow is my direction I look at the
hyper plane which is perpendicular to it
I want a point on the same side of the
hyperplane as the feasible region
okay it's a very simple task so I get
this point now given this point if that
point already satisfies everything I
want I'm done if not I get that some
constraints were violated the direction
are now interested in changes and this
is where the exponential update of the
dual weights come in and the direction
changes you see the direction is just
multiplication by 1 plus minus epsilon
okay now i have a new direction and i
have a new Oracle query and the Oracle
supplies me a new point and so this goes
on third and after a bunch of iterations
I have a collection of points they're
all over the place but the fascinating
thing is if I now take the average of
all these points i'm approximately
feasible so this is so the
multiplicative rate update method is
really really simple this is exactly
this picture okay so what do we know
about this there's a long history of
this we know that the dual weights
change slowly what are the dual weights
dual weights are this direction if you
look at a primal problem which use whose
feasibility want to solve the red arrow
is a particular assignment of the dual
variables which need not be feasible by
the way and these dual variables change
slowly and the problematic aspect of
multiplicative weight update method is
the directions are based on the
violations of the point which you
compute at every step this is not
particularly a great point we have just
seen that the final solution is the
average so the overall number of rounds
one needs is Rho epsilon cube log M this
is in aurora Hassan collie where m is
the number of constraints and I'm
assuming that you can compute these and
maintain these exact all weights so what
would happen if i apply multiplicative
weight update method to the LP which i
said i wanted to solve
the first thing the primal which are
which had many many many constraints
they were exponentially many constraints
corresponding to the odd set that means
there are exponentially many dual
variables you just kind of run this
that's one the second is the
optimization Direction depends on the
history that's another problem so let me
now switch a gear and talk about
fractional covering and packing problem
it's very similar to the multiplicative
rate update method and let's even see
what happens there so in this in
fractional covering and packing I would
start with the feasible point or in the
weaker polytope and I would try to get
to kind of move around and get to the
shaded blue region which is my
feasibility region okay so what
fractional covering does is again
assigns a dual wait exactly by the same
formula or almost the same formula now
instead of thinking about hyper planes
think of the following operation take
the point where you are and take the
improvement direction and ask the
question how far can I go in the weaker
polytope okay suppose you can solve that
optimization problem that's why you
choose the weaker pollito because the
optimization is easy so you get this
black point the second black point now
you say that okay that's as far as I can
go if I go that far clearly i'm at the
end of my weaker polytope that's not a
good thing so I will make a small step I
will only go a little bit and then you'd
stop so the red point is where you will
move to and then that's your new point
now you'll update your dual weights very
similar processes before you would again
compute the direction and you would
again find the extreme point as far as
you can go you would again take a tiny
step see if you can see that you're kind
of spiraling into the feasibility region
this is these two multiplicative wait
method and the fractional covering and
packing are very similar where they
differ is how you analyze the
convergence so think about what's
happening is you can analyze the step
size you get to control it and if you
think of the feasibility region and
concentric rings around it if you are
very far away you would take very large
steps if you are very close you will
take very small steps and once you kind
of let click this once you kind of do
that you can shave an epsilon off of the
convergence parameter if it becomes Rho
times epsilon to the minus 2 log N and
this actually has a lot of advantages
however here is something both of these
either multiplicative weight update
method or plot henchmen stylish you need
to compute the computer explicitly the
maximum violation so consider the
following problem how easier it is to
solve I give you a collection of edges
and I say that this is a maximum
matching can you find me the constraint
which is maximum violated this is a
non-trivial problem and this is the
minimum odd cut problem and the best
known result is a super quadratic at
this point okay so far it seems all the
methods we are looking at the number of
constraints is exponential finding the
maximum violation is hard even finding
the sign our constraints violated or not
is pretty hard and if you think about it
what is happening underneath all these
primal dual algorithms is a certain
concentration measure kind of argument
I'm increasingly becoming more sure that
I'm feasible and so 1 by epsilon Square
log of the number of constraints is a
very natural measure for that so how do
I get past this to solve matching I need
to do something where Capital m is into
the one by of silence so this is
this is not great so as i said i will
show you that you do not have to access
data but what we do it will start with
the duel and this is why i would say
that this is a dual primal algorithm so
what is it what is the dual of the
matching problem the duel of the
matching problem exact same problem
which I wanted to solve you now have a
variable X sub I which is four vertices
and you have Z sub you these are the
variables which corresponds to the odd
set which you had before and if you
believe that I can take a duel the duel
looks like this but something very nice
happened here instead of exponentially
many constraint I now have polynomially
many constraints of a constraint just
for each edge so that's something very
nice I of course have exponentially many
variables will find a way of dealing
with that so the more concerns is M the
duel primal method my weaker polytope I
would define is this if you think about
this that I want a solution which is
minimum i would want this to be at most
better and i would want all the edges to
be covered so far nothing exceptional
has happened ok now what is the width of
this polytope if i do not say anything
else the width is actually huge so keep
that thought in your mind now the rest
of the algorithm is kind of best
explained in a tongue-in-cheek way by an
Ellen gasps and this is something which
works very well with graduate students
or not always so I as the algorithm I
will say that this graph surely has a
small cover where cover is the duel
which you just saw in the last previous
page you clearly are not going to have
any of it you just think I'm out of my
mind and you get I said no no of course
not here is a matching
and now use weak duality therefore you
cannot have a small cover and what I
would say thank you very much the
matching is what I wanted this is
exactly how the algorithm will proceed
so the difference is in multiplicative
weight update method or the fractional
covering and packing which as discussed
what was happening is you wanted a
primal solution in you were managing
these dual weights Here I am actually
going to ask the Oracle to provide me
the final solution and all I would
construct is a certificate that the dual
is infeasible or feasible at some point
so the matching will be provided by the
Oracle now you can ask that okay you
haven't changed anything you haven't
changed anything so how are you getting
any benefit the benefit is if you think
of this Oracle and an algorithm approach
the resource constraints of the Oracle
are different from the resource
constraints of the algorithm and that is
what we can exploit so this is the rug
part now as I said before you can slowly
raise better and in powers of 1 plus
epsilon and it works out okay we just
talked about this so let's look at how
we solve this duel of a matching problem
I am going to run a primal dual on this
duel that means i would need oops that
means oops oops oops oops that means i
would need to sort of maintain a list of
weights uij keep in mind that you I jay
is now corresponding to every edge in my
graph and their small number of weights
what the all these multiplicative weight
update or fractional covering what you
saw the auxiliary problem which I need
to solve is this that given a set of
weights which was here multiply those
constraints by u IJ just add them up so
instead of solving M constraints
you reduce the M constraints into one
constraint so you recursively solve this
one constraint subject to the weaker
pollito is this clear that from an M
dimensional problem i have just reduced
it to a one-dimensional problem and
that's why these things work alright the
quantities uij can be computed using a
pass I won't talk about it these are
easy they're very easy actually now
think about this optimization which I've
asked you to solve the UI's you can also
be done by MapReduce forget how oracle
stores them i will use a cuts pacifier
think about the problem the Oracle has
to solve it has to solve these two
constraints what does this remind you of
it's a knapsack it's just knapsack all
I'm doing is I have some sets which have
some weight and this is my profit and I
want large profit subject to a knapsack
constraint it's really too it's as
simple as things get so it's a to
constraint problem now what I would do
and here is where the whole duel primal
thing works is you give me the weights
uij i am going to rescale them and
define y IJ and i will interpret these y
IJ as the variables in an original
matching LP then my task would be to
look for a collection of odd sets or
vertices which kind of solve which gives
me the best solution for the knapsack
it's a really simple problem ok how do I
solve this so what I would need is look
at these tight sets for which the odd
set constraints are violated and I will
just find a maximal disjoint collection
I will need to use
which is approximate go Murray who trees
it can be done in linear time I won't
get into it I just need approximation
okay so suppose those odd sets look like
that and they can be like all
intersecting in some small set suppose
since i'm finding a maximal collection i
find that one purple set which
intersects everything okay so far so
good now have two cases it's it's a very
simple proof from now on I have two
cases the collection which i have found
has a lot of mass interpreted in this
new variables y IJ if it does then it's
very simple if it doesn't that's the
second case if it has a lot of mass i
can just pick those sets and i can pick
them by a very large amount by 1 by
epsilon even though that doesn't make
sense it doesn't make sense to set X I
to 1 by epsilon but if I do this I can
satisfy those two constraints and that
would be sufficient for my prime
primal-dual framework to work what is
the other case the other case is the
maximal collection which I found has
very little mass the solution is very
simple just go ahead and delete them
because you found the maximal collection
every problematic constraint has been
eliminated in your solution you now have
a feasible solution and this is where I
am getting the Oracle to actually give
me a matching or a fractional matching
is that clear I make it a knapsack the
task for the Oracle is to give me a
collection of on sets with sufficient
mass if it cannot if it just were to
delete those subsets it already has a
fractional magic and that's it there are
issues that you need to represent this
in a compressed format and all this but
it works
out so what is the long story I if you
look at this each variable X I + zu gets
weight at most 1 by epsilon it's easy to
see that the width is 1 by of silent
it's just algebra which says that the
width is 1 by of silent and if you sort
of work out the entire math this gives
you total these many rounds but the
algorithm is really simple I would now
improve this algorithm okay so the
algorithm literally needs to solve
knapsack and just collect bunch of odd
sets okay now this is my width and the
width is 1 by of silent because by this
one I said that I will choose a
collection of disjoint odd sets it's the
disjoint pneus that lets me bound this
sum if I did not choose this joint art
set I'll have a problem okay let's see
okay so what is the algorithm doing this
is a recap I'm just collecting disjoint
dense cuts of size 1 by epsilon if you
care about a MapReduce implementation
all you need is every edge gets to know
the set it is in and that's a very
simple hash these sets are small that is
the key point in all of this okay to
improve the algorithm which I talked
about from 1 by epsilon cube log in all
the way to 1 by epsilon we'd need two
ideas the first idea which would be the
following I would use something which is
known as total dual integrality what
this says is assuming the edge weight is
an integer for an optimal solution the
dual of a matching polytope that
quantity is an integer for every vertex
and this optimum dual variables are also
they define a laminar family this is a
fantastic result and this has been
proved since 1978 and
tree of incredible research has gone
into this this is used in kind of the
minimum odd cart algorithm finding the
minimum T join but as far as I know this
is the first explicit use of these
inequalities to solve the linear program
the previous uses of TDI were implicit
in the sense that they said that there
exists a minimum out cut and we should
go find it I would actually write those
constraints down and satisfy them there
are there are a few problems the total
dual integrality is proved for all the
odd sets I'm not looking at all the odd
sets I'm looking at all these small odd
sets so that changes things but I would
now need to look at half integral
solutions and I would guarantee
something like this it's a little bit
weaker than total dual integrality but
it's pretty much the same that this
object is less than two times capital
lambda for all lambda greater than equal
to 1 what would happen is this is the LP
i said i would solve i would just stick
this constraint into my polytope which i
said was the easy polytope what would
that do if you now look at this
constraint and stare harder this
constraint the width of my formulation
is now a constant and that would take
care of one factor of epsilon the
feasibility holds for some parameter the
algorithm would provide some other
parameter that's not an important thing
but here is one thing which goes very
wrong and everybody thinks this is easy
till we come to this slide if you add
constraints to a primal your duel will
change so if you started with the
matching duel you started with the
matching problem and then you added
these constraints you now have a more
crazy eek but equivalent formulation of
the matching
and the solution you will get is to this
problem so it's an interesting task for
puzzle for you that if I give you a
feasible solution to this problem how
will you go and extract a matching and
this is what i see is most exciting here
that you just can't throw in constraints
even though it's very nice because then
you'll have to kind of pay for it later
so it's not obvious how to get a
matching from this but again we can
round and this is rounding here is from
one fractional solution to another
fractional solution we can do this so we
won't worry about so what happens so
using total dual integrality I can prove
my width is low but I still have to
solve this problem keep in mind the
collection what I said you are
collecting odd sets that will not
satisfy this so how will I solve this
problem I'm going to records that means
at an outer level I would solve the
problem which is on the slide at an
inner level i would use 1 by epsilon
rounds without this constraint it will
not matter to me because the inner level
is going to work in very on a very very
sparse graph that is the key here it's
the outer level which will only have to
access the edges once I do this I get
finally after all this 1 by epsilon
square login rounds now comes the next
main idea is that all these primal dual
algorithm the dual weights change slowly
in fact they change by 1 plus minus
Epsilon therefore if I in TI trations
the weight also change varies somewhat
small now if i can define a following
problem add efforts pacification problem
where you're given up
is that the edge weights will be within
some range so you construct a data
structure d such that after you have
constructed the data structure the exact
values are revealed if I use this here
is what I can do given the time let me
speed up a bit what I would do is I
would construct e different data
structures simultaneously and
independently I would use the first data
structure d1 to come solve my first
iteration of the problem after I have
solved the first hydration of my problem
my weights uij for the second iteration
are now revealed and completely
specified I would now use d2 but I will
not need to read the data again this is
the deference pacification what is
buying me so for I would construct
research pacifiers simultaneously I
would solve I would use d1 use the
result on d to use the result of d2 and
d3 and I will do this cascade 40 rounds
without looking at data again now if i
set the parameters right t become
something like 1 by epsilon log in and
the total number of rounds in which i
need access to data would decrease from
1 by epsilon Square log in to 1 by
epsilon square login / this T and
everything works out to order P by
epsilon passes so to recap here is what
we did we started from the duel of the
matching problem we added additional
constraint based on total duel
integrality we now ran almost standard
primal dual algorithm where we generated
dual of dual weights we interpreted
those dual of dual weights as the
inclusion in a matching and used efforts
pacifies on that
and using that we decrease the
adaptivity across the iterations the
task of the oracle became generate
either a primal witness either find me a
matching or prove a bound on the primal
so somewhere the match instead of me
constructing a matching problem I got
the Oracle to actually give me the
solution there is some details in this
in all of this this all needs to go on
simultaneously for all better it works
out and in this method what is really
critical that the structure or the
representation of the dual polytope was
critical the entire proof works because
of these TDI constraints which bound the
width and this is very exciting and it
takes me back to approximation
algorithms those of you who are familiar
with primal dual approximation
algorithms is the structure of the dual
problem which is more interesting for
such a primal dual approximation
algorithm because you construct a
feasible dual solution and then you kind
of try to get an integral primal
solution out of it so you really it's a
feasibility of the duel which is the
critical point and the structure of the
dual helps you get a better algorithm so
that's pretty much all i had to talk
about you heard about matching there are
lots of exciting history structure and i
seed matching as a canonical
combinatorial optimization problem in a
companion paper which is also in archive
we considered weighted capacity to be
matching and he gave the first fully
polynomial time approximation scheme for
that problem to me this is a tip of the
iceberg and we've just started
understanding fast and approximate
solution of combinatorial optimization
problems those of you who have followed
the recent work on electrical flows and
solving max flows faster that's another
instantiation of very similar phenomenon
and finally in the context of big data
there is a hopefully not a big divide
which is do you see a problem as a big
vector problem or a big graph problem in
all of streaming we always sees all this
estimation of statistical quantities
frequency moments norms these are to me
big vector problems I am very excited
about graphs and structure is probably
best encoded using graphs so it's a
natural open question for what kind of
big graph problems can you solve in
these resource constraint models that's
pretty much all i have to say thanks
so the question which Neal asked is can
i summarize where I managed to decrease
the adaptivity it came from the
following thing I would still run an
algorithm which takes 1 by epsilon
Square log n iterations however what I
would do is in one shot I would
construct 1 by epsilon login data
structures and each of these data
structures will provide me a
corresponding dual wait for that I
tration but I would not have to go back
to the data to construct them again so
it's a definite problem it's a delayed
evaluation problem because i have this
promise that the weights are within some
range yes so i can only do this because
i have something which is a cuts
pacifier and those of you who listen to
andrew stock i can construct these cuts
pacifier using sketches and if you stare
harder that algorithm it turns out that
it's an oblivious algorithm because it's
a sketch based algorithm if I just have
a guarantee that the weights are within
some range the algorithm will work just
fine that's what I'm using
you